welcome everyone everyone
ly will finish so i'm very happy
to see today thank you quai michel
for being present i'm wondering if
i can assure it people of any
event to be really at the thousand ha
for one  event ten thousand a so
it's a pleasure betty the year who
for the perfect sound everyone whose
jose put 10 million did so
the objective of the panel today is to
talk about subjects that  close to
heart then who is close to heart to our two
panelists really knows how
we can improve technology transfer
we see that we are a star
we are looking for finer publications
and but when we are in the field there
is really  a lack in the
marketing of these innovations there
i will start with a 3rd one including two
panelists michel is the founder
michel laflamme the founder and
president of and movie a
medical device company which is developed
only nico j the device  l which can
measure knee functions with
quantifiable young teams for him
with keffiyehs when there are the most 20
years of experience in business and
business development in
life sciences in biopharmaceutical in
medical devices
in 2008 she  received the first prize
for innovation and technologies in the
Quebec entrepreneurship competition with the
support of sme montreal desjardins
get there there montreal and form me the
group tts santé an organization that
helps companies in
medical devices and then commercialize
products in 2009  was a finalist two
engineers entrepreneurs of the year and a
lot of accomplishment and the on
the co2 smes world of metic and she
has a background like me makes it a
place the ass this king and if you have a baccalaureate
in electrical engineering from  night in saint
louis the harvard mba he is an
entrepreneur leader is recognized
is very advanced i think you
will have the chance to hear him there from  ssus
he co-founded acting out that just about
everyone but if you know is
also co-founder of medical resonance
who loved so much voters who
mourn our pre-
war company in radio oncology
gevrey as vice president at was
of health telesystem nostrils  of waters and
manager at mackenzie
presently he is managing director of
take scare non
profit organization which facilitates the creation of
partnerships ideas and more recently he
was commissioned by the minutes
the minister of economy kim made
for some way to help  solve the
problem I was talking about earlier,
that is to say the question is very
important for technology transfers
that's why today we will be
able to solve everything
exactly son and six minutes to introduce myself
- jerémie lavoie  i am the ceo of a
company called fx medical which
makes medical imaging analysis software
for the brain so if a
star  t up we work with milan we
are part of the space and pq where I
am presently is obviously as a
company name of the perspective very
very commercial we are therefore to
begin to really get to the heart
of the matter is what I  read that you
could start with me much more
of your experiences in
business marketing academic research
there are lessons to what you
learned it starts with that of listening in
a chair just loud just for fun
i will  talking a little bit about a
pair showed me little knew at
the time we what we did
marketing an elevation that had
been made to friends at the hatcheys it's
a system the technology behind
for  locate
in space a treatment room
the soft tissues the images of
soft tissues in space and finally in terms
of applications what we have done with this
is to be able to allow
the location of the tumor to be seen  who must be  be
written off during treatment
because the tumor it
moves it changes shape and
consequently the treatment
sent it to the tumor which is still fixed
in the same place too often misses the target
and destroys soft tissues
but worse a  lacks the quality of the
treatment
so we marketed it from
2003 by creating a company by doing
a spin-off so 2000 by financing part
of the pre-startup capital then all
the stages thereafter
and then in 2009 the company became
and the canada actor she continues to
market all of these
technologies of these products there but
she has also added a lot of
new products and technologies for you
it's stupid on my side he to michel thank you
their side have actually
marketed a device
The knee assessment is a
self-diagnosis tool when someone has
knee pain
it happens in movement
and then we go to see a doctor for
1 image  unfortunately I put two it does that
and the doctor must determine which
substance the x-ray the resonance
provide information which is
static so does not correspond to our the
patient's symptoms
the liquid j to give a little
nod to the ikhedji electrocardiogram
it is  a bit like
the cairo electrocardiogram but for the knee
it allows you to really understand the
causes and what is related to
the patient's symptoms
we have been using artificial intelligence
since 2008 in the system
to be able to therefore determine that
means the information for all for the
offense as a treatment
to information which is a signal
and then we tell him we
transform it into coherent language for the
doctor and the physiotherapists and
impressions we use
artificial intelligence also to say  what to do
is what can be done in the presence of
its deficits during these two sites of
these problems there it comes from 12
universities three in fa  it the École de
technologie supérieure polytechnique and
the CHUM so that it was necessary to negotiate
the agreements with three organizations
three development companies
it was in 2007 it took me a year and
then we acquired so
many rights  in 2012 for part then
of the jeep business there is we are we are we
remained under license
for artificial intelligence because we
know that artificial
intelligence algorithms a question of
continuous development of continuous collaboration
so we our modus operandi
it is to continue to collaborate invest
in research in Quebec with
university research institutions
thank you very much indeed we see
the examination of the knee also of the examination which
farts whether it is treadmill with an
exoskeleton suitable placed on the
condyles  to go really targeted the
capture the waters and that of
real-time movements so that's
our story with the letter the
organizations of re  looking
thank you very much sir what do
you think they explain the fact
that your two companies are
success stories an email you have
succeeded in commercializing
university research while several
others are less successful but I win
chief I myself  I was saying I think
you have the secret of success in front of you
the site an entrepreneur is not
the scientist then in a team with
the research team
but everyone with the misses and talent to
contribute I think it was a
great  difference
with us too the researcher had a
lot of intuition but a great
talent from the point of view of scientific depth
science but hey if we
teamed up with fred francis hallé
pâquis and myself françois father did we
also have already  who had more
business experience then who was in this world
this ability helps him to bring
things to market and then the duo it
's extras michel I don't know how
you experienced it my  is that's
actually a good answer
I think the secret where we're not
at the end of our troubles we get along we're
like still halfway to starting a
sizeable company but the secret is
in the expectations of  to clarify the
expectations of each
then in these ones to the researchers
entrepreneurs share that is to say that she
seeks to him wants to be able to publish us
we want to fill to be able to
market both it is possible that one even
been exponential because we  it
was to say m
to market you have to make
known you have to make noise point on
all the sets and the conferences and
that we invested in a
publication strategy we said to ourselves what
should we publish
?  you have to go back to the basics do a
literature review you have to after having
documented yourself in the technological validation
this time the teeth in the
clinical journals every day bow that I
had to be documented by clinical studies
every point we wanted  it each
anger points that we wanted to prove
like cattle reduced pain
must be demonstrated its reduced strength
we noticed the function to demonstrate if
we say that patients are more
satisfied we must demonstrate that salam
sall led we are now more  only
100 publications then it's a solid file
it's a solid file for when we
present the product to buyers
to takers
but the file is a checkmark ok I
leave that it's done
the file is credible now it's  It's
more a question of
implementation logistics it's
business model logistics
but that's the kind it's a shame
because in our case the cts didn't exist
so we couldn't benefit from his
advice  there and we made the mistake of
not doing it and we lost years
like that by the way that we could
get there otherwise but you're so
right the depth as soon as it gives
with the publications
we focused a lot on that
would create redemption codes
for use of
the technology is also ensured to have
a legion of patents not only
ours so we had shot with martin
the chain had a
very elaborate patent strategy for the basic patent
of a strategy of  offensive defensive patents
too and then we took out
licenses for a few hundred
patents from Canadian universities to
ensure a good base for defense
and possibly can be certain that
good we would do it there is no one then
we pay an odious  to the people that he had
developed the imaging technologies
it's good points then to Saussines
dynamism strategy of opinion leaders
that is to say opinion leaders from the
quays ol who can endorse who
participated in the same clinical messages
clinical white bac quarrels but
also recently since since the
commercial launch that one did in
2010 9.2 according to it really is with the
case model since taste
m  arketing we have been looking for we are not
working on the serene
branding marketing strategy with
ambassadors whose rendering is late
bruny surin
these were key it was really
dirty created a good impact for my
estimate was made too soon
it's not  good since but when we are there
we have there the credibility we have the
patents in which he is
impressive as a client as an
example client that you allowed to bring back
to the game a few weeks ungrateful sony
who is said it's hard to find better
yes we had the chance to work that
the kidney, which had pain in the knee for
two years, began the injury which
was which had left residual pain
then in three weeks but
despite the fact that they were
for the best the
best  doctors best physio the
pain don't go away no at least three
weeks
it's gone like that because we're
in that one cause of his pain
and then he falls to know now the
for  the geography of the exam entrusts
with with the system of the kids is
impressive because this foot 5,300
lines of the hands big command
computer has something that I
regret that we have done from time
now that I work I will
take the  promoters
finance collaborative innovation so a
company that works with an
academy researcher and his students his
laboratory which remains in the simple
beyond the academic environment we us the
researcher
but that can be a mistake because
today in tournissan because of  a
great leader who learned to become CEO
who learned the job of
business management who was very very good
there was this cry the medal the price of
québec he is a great ambassador but
now I see how we can
win  to keep the
research professor in their lab in
the university and then to combine the two
and then to develop a partnership an
alliance and then to propel things
together from  develop together which to
benefit from more plans by doing so
our competitors had made it benefit
from with only 22 million you have
developed extraordinary technologies
in fact that and but
because it had remained in the university of
mit loi who says that we  we didn't
have to take out the researchers
to bring them to our heroes thanks
to the r & d tax credits
but it took a lot of
risk capital here's really interesting that
then in relation to that it brings us  a
subject that I find interesting if we
all know that the interests of
precisely researchers and helping people
how many are not always united by a
chair thanks to what you were doing on
the publication strategy because
precisely
a creation in our  own industry
it is not as important as when
health in health at least one of this
interest of the united states where the researcher as
much if not more interior publishes than
of the company for its
co  mercialisation
or do you see interests that
they are online and already that they
should be
I ask an open question
what can we do in relation to his life
says like that the first one who tells us  comes
what is fairly well known that is that of
intellectual property or didier
of researchers in preference to put
their work in open source because it
allows greater adoption that
seems to say that it gives an advantage
to hold certain grants but
obviously  if technology in open
source and why these two there patented
then the need for patenting hyper
important consented
it is the first jet of
intelligent search of the web was invented
at mcgill university was put in open
source
and then we know the  next we have a
point in relation to that then the tone and
gable on the street
the title continues I can I think we
have no choice and today at the
speed where we have to develop it ca
n't we can't close the  things because
we must rather develop ways
a cardboard passed to the banks or
ways to exploit commercially
what can be certain elements which are
made public for the for the
development of science of
technology of the knowledge of humanity
how  after being able to
quickly able to not that I have these
things there added value if there are
over and above patenting elements then
also you have to realize when you put
things in open source
they are not always necessarily
put
how  to say the license is property
is not to give to so when you
use open source material it is
usable but there is still a life
without attaching
there are still rights the
creators there are when there are ways
of for the generators of countries which
put in open-source of to use it
as a way of developing the context to
develop the industry but to be able
all the same to remain at the heart of this
development so it is  good and it's
dangerous you have to use the good side
of the force in the three lions to me
if I spoke previously in the
rather interesting concept but a little
what is the concussed there are
people who are born two of his
open source models
I think it's by opening it up she
swears that we often attract the right
collaborators
it's also how we make ourselves
known you have to know I think I'll
use this open source game every time
'a case in point is not cabba
everyone knows of course to
people who have been able to join his two
proteges all that but at the same time it
is perhaps a way to protect
certain applications and patents
it'  maybe is for just solicited
it maybe there are other ways to
protect the property the current one but
each case is a case in point but all
my games agree with him that we do
n't  the choice
now we are no longer in
manufacturing we were in the parties
a company  been made by a
knowledge society
it was to know its deserts goris
cd databases to exceed
pooling of information so we have no
choice to make do with
it we have to find new ways
to go  throw the rounds are given
tangier sound systems therefore account to do
and income with that of protecting themselves in
there then banks
commercial agreement with good players know
oh time suspend attention because I
confess to you that I will wait that's what
that I don't mind but it can be worth
it being as much as patents
because the patent don't forget that
it's a right to defend yourself the
inversions require it
but it's still I have the right
to defend myself that doesn't  not prevent
some of our competitors from copying us
then all that will have the
financial means to defend in science on
the health page we had found it
difficult to integrate open source
among other things because we must validate
each component of the  product able
to have detailed traceability of the
design to be able to go back to
the back of issues
that arise to be able to
put corrective measures in place
so hard open-source ir it requires this
level additional difficulties for
the  validate in closed systems then
in regulatory contexts and at
millas then I think we are going towards that we are there
abè it is a whole other universe the
tale first yes exactly then precisely
parents of universes to approach the
question of how the  case of quebec
canada because there is this perception
the case we are particularly debate
launched between excellence in research
then difficulties in
commercialization
the question for you too
do you think it is true and what is it
what says what we can do to
facilitate the transfer of knowledge
of technology transfers or at the
end of the long term we end up not
only with papers that have
b  a lot of stations that are very
interesting but we end up
with companies that can really
benefit from these Japanese innovations 2
you have a lot of opinion on this
I can give perhaps a
recent personal experience
firstly the first license that
I  I negotiated in 2006 relating to prices
ona it's very long you really have to be
persevering then it's because there are a
lot of people
involved there are a lot of issues this
is one of the brakes recently this year
their 2020 he started dossier  to
negotiate three institutions do not
begin to negotiate the rights
I think that these modes of February March
for the nail skin file still it is
very long because each each
institution has a different vision of
the protection of these countries
then we are as if taken  in these
three visions their cons we can't
change university or
institutional practices we try to find
compromises
so it's the lack  ue of coherence in
the universities currently facing their
country is a brake because it is said in
duplicate it is no longer the technologies
are no longer developed in a vacuum are
developed the researchers collaborate
are the talk of princess but we
talk about collaboration  open
so there is even cooperation
with other issues overseas the when we
talk about a president of trans given
birth to a company or to transfer
the rights in company it is the chain
of occitanie complexes etc except would have to
simplifying that is one of the barriers in
québec.le which prevents us the
lack of uniformity the lack of a beyond
to have a common vision of the apei that
's it slows down the files a lot
then to such  point a lot
of entrepreneurs don't want to
rack the public research environment
because it's too long too long then
after that the key being
in long term collaboration is sadistic
false work coves in collaboration m  But
it's the dependents of the students who
go to the kiffer file are two
positions that this year a grant
for with it's a lot it's longer
but the
degree of quality is incredible I
believe in what I say to myself ok it's  is long
but that's okay
we want a
disruptive innovation company
we can't be a myth where and when
we invest in this approach the man
and sapho have faced big
big threads that relate  i think a lot
about this divergence of visions on monday
contracting jeremy above des bains
the figures of the data speaks
for itself
it is a matter of opinion quebec
which is far behind in its 37th in
the statistics of the utm on  with so much
patented marketed technology
versus the dollars invested in r&d
well it's surprisingly good that they have
bread poillion danse and we had we have
this intuition man when we look at
the figures it's cruel it's hard  then
fortunately in the lead  a small star
that shines a little is in terms
of research contracts but we are a little
stronger in Quebec perhaps than
elsewhere then we manage to make a
mass research contract and
collaborations precisely when
companies like is dedicated  movie pts
where we work together on a
common project flat country is shared or a
disagreement between two countries at that time there
is a commercialization without having
patents necessarily because it is
and if we are a little stronger on it
because  transfer also speaks of
knowledge by the students
themselves by joint work by the
creation of highly
qualified labor who trace ferry that this
is a little a little balm on the
wound I think that somewhere a
cultural question we do not have for the
most part many researchers
many companies in graduate students
this notion is misunderstood
so what you are doing today
is good cont  contributes to the promotion
the popularization of the importance of
technology transfer the opportunity of
technology transfer for many and
then there is also a question of having to
be a little more seasoned to
put in place people there in the
field
who  going to be scouts who are going to
work who are going to be part of the
teams who are going to meet around the
coffee machine with the researchers also
how to be able to understand a
little
what is happening with the young people or idiots
or concepts or  business knowledge
vs able to unearth plant
the seeds of say i'm not saying you got
hell here then maybe something to
do carefully to bring it to
society led it to all
technical businesses create a spin  off with that
but I can add that as a challenge there
is the whole question of trying to
talk about others at the beginning the expectations
there was I think a vision in Quebec
to think that pop was to make and
rich  your income progress
at university but the real wealth and
in job creation in the list
of r&d investments the milk
social pact in the health sector it is
the same time it is the improvement of the health care
system  health but that it is
in others are by the attack but it is
the advent of a new tool is at
all of which there is an impact on
society and an expert in terms of order
then his one forgets  that it's the
best and not that it's the best
it's the best investment
while we treat the country with our backs so
like we have to talk about royalty
that returns you to university but there
the figures on it on the sidewalks
maybe closer to reality than
me but I think that reassures them but
he at the university
knows russia historically this hope laddh of
10 this one is that of the balm to
make us rich and consequently  to
negotiations
if it happens once in 1000 but
because it is the unive  rsity who pay
the transfer work bill
the equation marc never as
michel says because it is society the
government the health systems the
institutions in the cellars this created by
the jobs thereby
taxation in successful companies and
everything happened, you know, like what the
government decided to say, we're going to
stop asking universities to
pay the bill for the transfer of
enhancement,
it's something that is essential
for society, for modern Quebec,
you to create  successful companies
that will create wealth for
Quebec society is able to
afford social services, culture and
all the institutions that we love and
that we want to keep very strong, but
we will therefore take our responsibilities
and then say ok if it's  is important
for society
it is the society that will take care of it that
will pay for its positive ratings
precisely because it
needs innovation in the bottom benchicou
milli  we are essentially a
start up we have a space here because
the basic idea was to have
physical space for companies
to interact obviously
there are very good reasons why yapo
brunet direction these days you have
become  why then I think it
's interesting because that's the points
we're talking about and the they've already
run out of time but the
current government's desire to centralize
technology transfer work
under its leadership too much for the start  of the
project should be able to help report
problems as highlighted and
consistency
is what we can have a scoop it's
an old game all the scoops we
could maybe but stay and pass
some of the information published
soon but the  centralized it
may be a difficult word it's good
we're going rather than scattering we're going to
make sure we have consolidated
resources for really the real pros
have more resources to be  be more
astute more competent more
knowledgeable more connected to the markets
on the verticals on the niches be
able to have resources
to explore understand the
opportunities in the markets and at the same
time also perhaps have more
resources to be able to  to have
the scouts in the field
the local presence then first of all
finally there is something
new which is announced it is
moreover at the level of the funds of
maturation it will increase to be able to
mature and a little the technologies but
also the pre-seed fund there to
help with the creation of a business then
the spin-off the business start-up or
the business support of a center which
come from public research results
like that I got a little
dog  here that he doesn't understand at all the
concept of wever it's all the time
we have thank you very much
michel michel could perhaps go a bit
of the way sir the facts in fact we
can maybe-  being left to people
that there is a splitting of questions by
waiting for the questions to appear
what I can say is that we must
also bet on education because it
will be unavailable between the horse and
perhaps the researchers  universities
think the technology is ready to
be commercialized like this but a
very substantive work to be done that
targets much larger than we
even compensate in cash the entrepreneur
I thought to walk around on my own
then I make them you defeat at  a few
times but it's always slower
longer more more expensive than I think
at the beginning then already I had a hard
knowledge with what is the university
of paragliders effect that really needs to be
explained the manager will not
start pronouncing  also the exam here are
the steps i'm going to have to do the
newspaper rest airlock but so ed and
me you have to focus then it was
you have to maybe think about them in
the formations and such
what does it mean by
marketing an innovation all the
way through the maze you have to
pass your poses at that screaming scissor bridge
that risk-taking is often not
well understood this after incidents
it reconciliation of expectations of
our university and entrepreneurs yes the
system of public questions per year
by boat of the coherence between the
different ali because indeed it is
already so much work of barton
company sion in addition we have to
hold
we speak to different people who  have
different speeches from its
university shares at the provincial or federal level and
that as the company we have the
objective of selling in the United States so
the objective is added another level of
complexity
we are really something
we really have potential in
an increase in consistency in
question in relation to training says
what can quebec do to
promote to promote training
in  entrepreneurship for example at the level
of researchers I can tell you my
point of view on this it is I think
that the person who decides to be a
researcher in his life must see for
the profile to become entrepreneurs and
the people who want it
entrepreneurial profile and provins the last
person good to give researchers
i think a good collaboration is
essential between the two the street term
in the united states themselves makes state
gives me to hear the children on the
need to develop high quality
inheritance by  pid researchers
do good marketing
by entrepreneurs who fall in love with a fake
to think that 2 km you are asking a
researcher to become an entrepreneur
fortunately this pressure that we put
the system on the researcher so that he
you leave a spin off so that he
leaves but why does he not put in
collaboration with someone who can
do it in parallel that everyone will
see there the job that  i fit with his profile t
because it's a it's a it's
a lot of pressure we put on
researchers to say we'll see on this topic
show them how you are an
entrepreneur then i worked with
researchers education it could
be possible
I think that in the curriculum it
could be one of the basic things
the valorization society the
universities could also develop
a curriculum then training to
allow a culture of innovation
understanding of these things
not  to become an entrepreneur like
michel on may 10 understand how you
can team up with entrepreneurs
how a technology can be
implemented in the market who to
work with this ring of points these
banks difficult to find
precisely the ball carrier to
entrepreneurs it's like  leave
things a bit up to the chance of
dating life and maybe someone who
could beat one should structure
and ability to have  puglia
of entrepreneurs train entrepreneurs
who will be able to be one of the
ball carriers of research results of
academic discoveries of discoveries
made by academia and all
that there are foundries it's a model
that began to exist between tac
have driven with one love tandem language
that we know who private trades that
exist and who often don't have it's a
job and inventing things in a
few days but the poor clinicians
who are suddenly told well yes
it's  superb even got out across
the country then beat a company it's
not his job
michel is right but we have to see more
find ways structure is
to support access to people who
will be ball carriers to be able to
cross  some blockers like the
real radishes they also go excellent
it's super interesting
I hope we'll have the chance to
hear more of them since well yes the
Portuguese martin coup we are told it's
one of the  big conferences every year
we talk about country issues like that
three years ago and a big forum if
I was joking jeremy these questions
there we can talk about them for days
with specialists in all
fields then the strong peak lower a
big conference  was organized
by this group of motivated volunteers which
will take place in the spring
so we will all participate in it
to have this kind
of exchange of reflection then to
feed ourselves as a practitioner there
the valuation of the transfer of
intellectual property  we have a
lot to learn to become
skills to look at ourselves in the
best in the world and then these kinds of
things or until we have an
organized structure it remains a very
high court in the sense
that people have to  meet by leaving
personal contacts
so if on May 13, 2021
I hope we can do it in
person
so it's perfect thank you everyone thank you very
much  ent
we mounted 35 participants in the spade
today it was easy that
you all came for subjects like
on the thank you for having organized his jeremy
thank you to the minors for doing
round tables like that thank you for the invitation